so how are you doing today
oh great good yeah you sure it's making
me very happy I think it's funny I don't
think you bought that here I wear this
to every junket I'm so glad in honor of
this of this blue character is there
anything that you yourself can do very
well very fast uh this is gonna make me
sound like I my father had the same
ability I can drink a beer okay I've
never been beat in a beer chuckle - and
that sounds really [ __ ] I wish I knew
that before this yeah I can see could've
brought out in a rules or something and
we could have gone to town it's a family
film now right well it's not like but
yeah I've I learned that in college
actually if you're gonna be the funnel
and it just they put the two thing beers
in and just went zip because I can like
open up my throat just like and they
were like whoa so yeah it's a useless
talent but it's a fun bar gag yeah this
movie also revolves both you character
and sonic around a bucket list I'm
wondering when you look back on your
career was there it was there a
professional bucket list or anything on
you professional bucket lists that you
can remember that I that I've achieved
so far I mean one huge one I just got to
take office was working with Jim Carrey
I mean that was like he was a hero of
mine a comic hero and and watching him
and sharing scenes with him and was was
pretty special
you know there's directors that I've
worked with that like you know that
that's awesome you know it was I'm
trying the actors and spectacular actors
I've worked with playing a I can iconic
comic book character and Cyclops in
x-men was definitely a bucket list check
so I've been very fortunate I looked
back to be able to have the like
latitude to jump from comedy to drama to
action to all kinds of things and I mean
to me my whole career is a bucket list
right I didn't expect this to actually
you know continue as long as it has and
I hope today I did it would but but yeah
I grew up in Oklahoma and you know I you
know you you get a you get a real job
but you know working at a business
nine-to-five job there and and I was
like I didn't it didn't feel right to me
so the fact that I still have this
career is pretty special and definitely
the bucket list in general you mentioned
your your foray into into comic book
movies we're still living through these
comic book movies and I'm wondering if
you had advice for a hypothetical future
new Scott Summers what that place would
be yeah I guess the biggest challenge
was that was never the audience and
other actors never being able to see
your eyes it was like it definitely was
a handicap in like bringing bringing a
persona to the character and an energy
to the character that to a character who
also is very by nature very by the books
and very you know a boy scout and do the
right thing you know and it's a is a
foil to to Wolverines character who's
like more fly by the seat of his pants
and a little more unpredictable and
aggressive so I mean I would just say
you know just just lean into it and own
it and and and carve out your own thing
like that you know the fans in the books
are gonna tell you like it needs to be
this like you know to find your a new
way to make it interesting you know
because it is it is tough to like you
know get something interesting and cool
and different across when you don't no
one ever sees your eyes which is
obviously the main part of character